O termo teletransporte quântico pode soar como coisa de ficção científica, mas, como vamos falar no episódio de hoje
do Qiskit na sala de aula, é uma técnica muito real e muito útil para comunicação quântica e
redes quânticas. Bem-vindo ao Qiskit na sala de aula. Nesta série, usamos o Qiskit para explorar alguns conceitos fundamentais
comumente abordados em cursos relacionados à computação quântica. Cada vídeo é acompanhado de um módulo interativo
com o link na descrição abaixo, então não deixa de conferir. O teletransporte é praticamente um elemento
da ficção científica e fantasia a essa altura. Uma pessoa ou objeto desaparece de um lugar e aparece instantaneamente em outro.
Por mais incrível que isso fosse, infelizmente esse tipo de teletransporte é impossível. Violaria o limite cósmico de velocidade —
nada pode viajar mais rápido que a luz. Mas o teletransporte quântico é
possível. No teletransporte quântico, informação — e não matéria — pode ser transmitida entre dois
locais distantes. Tudo que você precisa é de um par de partículas entrelaçadas, uma em cada local, e um meio de comunicar informações clássicas
entre os dois locais. Esse protocolo foi desenvolvido em 1993 por uma equipe
de cientistas quânticos, incluindo Charles Bennett da IBM. Eles o chamaram de teletransporte quântico porque, de forma similar à versão de
ficção científica, a informação quântica desaparecia de um local e aparecia em outro distante
sem nunca ter viajado pelo espaço entre eles. Pode soar como magia, mas, como veremos, não há nada
misterioso ou mágico nisso. É possibilitado pelo fenômeno do entrelaçamento quântico junto com a
comunicação clássica. Hoje vamos percorrer o protocolo de teletransporte quântico e como ele funciona. Depois vamos colocá-lo em
ação em um computador quântico real para teletransportar o estado de um qubit de um lado de um processador quântico da IBM para
o outro. Então é assim que o teletransporte quântico funciona. Suponha que temos duas pessoas, Alice e Bob, que estão separadas
por uma grande distância. Digamos que Alice tem um qubit. Vamos chamar esse qubit de Q, só por conveniência. E ele está em algum
estado quântico desconhecido sq, onde alfa 0 e alfa 1 são números complexos.
Alice quer enviar seu estado para Bob, mas ela não tem como realmente enviar o qubit em si. Pode ser que
ele esteja muito longe, ou talvez ela nem saiba exatamente onde Bob está, então não sabe para onde enviá-lo. Por sorte,
os amigos já compartilham um par de qubits entrelaçados A e B, onde Alice tem o qubit A e Bob tem o qubit B. E
esses qubits estão entrelaçados. Por entrelaçados, quero dizer que, mesmo que os dois qubits estejam separados por uma grande
distância, seus estados são correlacionados de uma forma que a física clássica não consegue explicar. Esse par entrelaçado é
chamado de ebit, que podemos usar como recurso na computação e comunicação quânticas.
Neste caso, Alice pode usar o ebit como recurso para transmitir sua informação quântica a Bob. Para ver como, vamos
começar escrevendo o estado conjunto de todos esses três qubits, onde ordenei os qubits de forma um tanto arbitrária
por ora, mas essa ordenação será conveniente quando rodarmos nosso experimento no Qiskit. No Qiskit, o jeito padrão de
ordenar os qubits é da direita para a esquerda. Então o estado do qubit zero aparecerá à direita.
Vamos expandir o estado um pouco e reescrevê-lo assim. O primeiro passo no nosso protocolo de teletransporte é
Alice entrelaçar seu qubit de dados com a metade do ebit que ela possui usando um gate C-NOT. Um gate C-NOT ou controlled-NOT
vai mudar o estado de um qubit — o qubit alvo — dependendo do estado de outro qubit, o qubit de controle.
Se o qubit de controle está no estado zero, nada acontece com o alvo. E se o qubit de controle está no
estado um, então o qubit alvo é invertido. Então neste caso, o qubit de dados Q de Alice será o qubit de controle e
o qubit do ebit A de Alice será o qubit alvo. Então os dois primeiros termos não foram alterados pelo C-NOT, mas os
dois últimos foram, porque o qubit de controle Q estava no estado um. Então Alice
aplicaria um gate Hadamard ao seu qubit de dados Q, que leva o estado 0 ao estado 1/√2 (|0⟩ + |1⟩) e o estado 1 a
1/√2 (|0⟩ - |1⟩). Vou pular um pouco de álgebra simples aqui, que você pode tentar completar por conta própria se quiser.
Mas depois de reorganizar alguns termos, você vai obter um estado que se parece com este. Então agora o estado entrelaçado
de três qubits de Alice e Bob parece uma bagunça completa. Mas veja o que acontece se Alice mede os dois qubits dela. O estado de três
qubits vai colapsar parcialmente para um desses quatro
termos. E em cada caso, Bob ficará com um estado de superposição com amplitudes que estão relacionadas ao
estado inicial desconhecido de Alice. Lembre-se de que as amplitudes são alfa 0 e alfa 1. Então,
por exemplo, se Alice medir os dois qubits como zero, o estado de Bob vai colapsar para este termo — o estado
original desconhecido que Alice queria teletransportar. Mas se Alice medir zero no qubit A e um no qubit Q, então o
estado de Bob será este. Esse estado pode ser transformado no estado original do qubit Q se Bob
aplicar um gate Z, que vai inverter esse sinal aqui. Mas Bob não vai saber fazer isso
até saber o que Alice mediu. Então o próximo passo no protocolo é Alice ligar para Bob e dizer a ele o que
ela mediu. Depois que ele souber disso, vai saber quais operações realizar no seu qubit para que ele corresponda ao
estado original de Alice. Aqui está uma tabela das quatro medições possíveis e as quatro operações possíveis que Bob
precisará realizar no seu qubit com base nessas medições. Bob pode precisar aplicar um gate Z, um gate X ou ambos para
transformar seu qubit para corresponder ao qubit original de Alice. Essa última etapa, em que Alice liga para Bob, é por isso
que o teletransporte quântico não viola a causalidade. Mesmo que o estado de Bob tenha colapsado instantaneamente quando Alice mediu
seus qubits, Bob não conseguia extrair nenhuma informação desse estado até Alice dizer a Bob o que ela mediu. E
essa ligação era limitada pela velocidade da luz. Passamos por muita matemática detalhada, então o fato incrível de
que acabamos de teletransportar informação quântica pode ter se perdido. Mas é realmente muito incrível. Usando
o entrelaçamento como recurso, Alice pôde fazer uma medição para destruir a informação quântica armazenada com ela e fazê-la
aparecer em outro local distante com Bob. Essa distância pode ser de centenas, até milhares de quilômetros. Ainda mais
incrível, esse protocolo nem exige que Alice saiba exatamente onde Bob está. Contanto que compartilhem um ebit
e possam se comunicar classicamente, o teletransporte quântico vai funcionar. Agora vamos ver como isso funciona
com o Qiskit e realmente teletransportar um estado quântico em um computador quântico.
Vamos começar com três qubits: um para o qubit de dados Q e os qubits A e B que vão compor o ebit.
Começamos criando o ebit. Aplicamos um Hadamard no qubit A, seguido de um C-NOT
entre A e B para criar o estado entrelaçado que queremos.
Depois preparamos o qubit Q de Alice em um estado quântico aleatório aplicando uma unitária aleatória, mostrada por essa caixa rotulada
U. Então vem o teletransporte. Primeiro o C-NOT entre os qubits Q e A. Depois o Hadamard no
qubit Q. Depois as medições colapsam parcialmente o estado, de modo que apenas o qubit B de Bob está em superposição.
Esse é o ponto em que Alice ligaria para Bob e diria a ele o que ela mediu. Então Bob aplicaria alguns
gates dependendo dessas medições. Essas caixas com contorno vermelho indicam gates condicionais. A primeira significa
que Bob aplica um gate X ao seu qubit se o qubit A foi medido como um. E
a segunda significa que ele aplica um gate Z também se o qubit Q foi medido como um.
Então Bob deve ter um qubit no mesmo estado em que o qubit de Alice estava neste ponto, após o gate unitário.
Se tudo correu como planejado, teletransportamos o estado quântico. Mas como verificamos isso? Podemos rodar o
mesmo circuit, mas fazer uma pequena mudança.
Aqui adicionamos outra unitária bem no final do circuit, aplicada ao qubit de Bob. Essa unitária é o inverso da
que aplicamos no início ao qubit de Alice. O raciocínio é que se esse primeiro gate criou o estado
quântico que agora foi teletransportado para o qubit de Bob, então esse deve desfazê-lo, levando o qubit de Bob de volta ao estado zero.
Mas é claro que isso desfaz todo o nosso trabalho duro de teletransportar o estado em primeiro lugar. Então não iríamos querer
fazer isso se realmente quiséssemos fazer algo com o estado teletransportado, e se ele estivesse verdadeiramente em um estado quântico desconhecido
não poderíamos aplicar uma unitária para desfazê-lo. De qualquer forma, isso é puramente para fins de diagnóstico, para
ter certeza de que o teletransporte foi bem-sucedido. Se medirmos o qubit de Bob no estado zero, podemos ter razoável
certeza de que o teletransporte funcionou. Uma vez que tenhamos certeza de que nosso protocolo está funcionando como esperado, poderíamos remover essa
unitária final e realmente fazer algo com o estado teletransportado. Mas por ora, vamos só garantir que funciona. Vamos
executar o circuit em um computador quântico. Podemos usar o sampler primitivo do Qiskit para rodar esse circuit
muitas vezes e coletar estatísticas sobre os resultados das medições. Se tivéssemos teletransportado perfeitamente o estado de Alice para Bob em todas as
vezes, Bob mediria seu qubit como zero sempre. Mas com ruído ambiental e imperfeições nos
gates, podemos esperar ver algumas execuções onde o qubit de Bob acaba sendo um. Mas contanto que na maioria das
vezes o qubit de Bob seja medido como zero, podemos chamar de sucesso. Aqui temos um histograma dos resultados das medições de
todos os três qubits. A medição de Bob é mostrada como o primeiro slot de cada string de três bits. Como esperado, os quatro
resultados que correspondem ao bit dele sendo zero são muito mais prováveis que os outros quatro. Então teletransportamos com sucesso
um estado quântico. Mas veja até onde teletransportamos. Esse é um mapa de todos os
qubits no processador quântico que usamos. E no experimento, usamos apenas esses três qubits.
O qubit de Alice estava aqui e o de Bob estava aqui. Então eles estavam quase lado a lado. Poderíamos ter
conseguido o mesmo resultado aplicando alguns gates de swap, que, como o nome sugere, apenas trocam os estados quânticos
de dois qubits vizinhos. O teletransporte quântico é útil para transportar informação quântica por longas distâncias, e
estados quânticos já foram teletransportados por centenas de quilômetros. Para nossos experimentos aqui, somos limitados pelo
tamanho do chip, mas poderíamos tornar o teletransporte um pouco mais impressionante ao teletransportar um estado entre dois
qubits distantes no nosso computador quântico. Então vamos tentar. Aqui está nosso novo diagrama de circuit. Parece um pouco mais
complicado, mas nada mudou fundamentalmente, exceto que agora Alice e Bob criam seu ebit compartilhado,
e depois se separam. Essa série de linhas e X's representa gates de swap que movem
os estados de Alice e Bob de um qubit para outro. Alice se move para o qubit 1 e
Bob se move para o qubit 12. Então Alice cria seu estado aleatório no qubit 0 com
essa unitária. Lembre-se de que ela está criando o estado depois que ela e Bob já
se separaram. Então Bob já está longe dela.
Depois o protocolo de teletransporte continua como antes, e Bob acaba com o estado original de Alice após suas
operações condicionais. Aplicamos o gate unitário inverso e depois verificamos se o qubit de Bob está
no estado zero. E de novo vemos que na maioria das vezes o qubit de Bob foi encontrado no estado zero.
Então o teletransporte foi bem-sucedido.
A taxa de sucesso não é bem tão alta quanto quando Alice e Bob estavam lado a lado. Todos esses gates de swap
podem ser caros e fazer o ebit degradar um pouco. O teletransporte quântico pode parecer mágica, mas como vimos,
tudo que é preciso é entrelaçamento, um canal de comunicação clássica e um pouco de criatividade. A proposta original de 1993
que abordamos neste vídeo formou a base para outros protocolos, como o teletransporte de gate quântico,
e é um ingrediente essencial para a computação e as comunicações quânticas.
No front experimental, cientistas continuaram a expandir os limites do teletransporte quântico, chegando inclusive a teletransportar
o estado quântico de um fóton entre um laboratório na Terra e um satélite a 1.400 km
acima dela. E a teletransportar estados quânticos por um cabo de internet clássico com ruído. Se você quer teletransportar seu próprio
estado quântico, acessa o módulo de teletransporte quântico com o link na descrição abaixo. Obrigado por assistir
e até a próxima!